[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys weil es
ja manchmal sagen na ja woran hat sich
ein weihnachtsmenü gewünscht und hier
haben wir dieses jahr habe ich mir
gedacht machen wir ein menü was man
super vorbereiten kann
deswegen gibt's lambo lasch mit spinat
knödeln und gefüllte paprikaschoten und
honig mehr sparen was anderes als skater
salaminews thw könnte aber schreiben was
ist für euch traditionellen immer bit
und ja ich meine feiere weihnachten
jetzt eigentlich nicht so sondern
braucht man halt immer immer einfach ein
schöner abend genau wie beim kochen hat
immer das war es auch was wahlgrab lust
haben und jetzt hatten wir irgendwie
lust auf la molina und am ende probieren
wir dann alle gemeinsam
wichtig bei diesem menü ist im prinzip
dass er hat alle zutaten da habt und
dann können das wirklich schon am vortag
vorbereiten weil viele haben das problem
die wollen zwar was aufwendiges kochen
aber am leben tag am weihnachtstag eben
nicht so lange in der küche stehen
und hier können da alles super
vorbereiten und dann seid ihr für eure
familie noch freunde dort
so machen wir das und ich fange jetzt
zuerst einmal an mit dem spinat kalorien
für die knödel verwende ich eine zwiebel
1 knoblauchzehe 500 gramm tiefgefrorenen
spinat dann habe ich bereits aufgetaut
40 gramm butter schmalz 50 gramm gerade
pagano hier habe ich 500 gramm altes
brot bereits in würfel geschnitten etwas
mit salz pfeffer und muskat und streuer
ich nehme jetzt zuerst mal die zwiebel
und die knoblauchzehen die werden jetzt
geschält und fein geschnitten und es ist
echt was tolles kann einfach super
vorbereiten knödel die gehen halt immer
[Musik]
irgendwas ist anders wie sonst ich kann
doch kein weihnachts willi machen ohne
weihnachten im hintergrund
[Musik]
also jetzt einfach feine würfelchen
schneiden was sie jetzt schon machen
könnt den das butterschmalz erhitzen in
der pfanne einfach hier die pfanne und
dann bei mittel hoher hitze erwärmen
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich die zwiebel und
knoblauch höfen hier anbraten einfach so
lange bis sie glasig sind
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt der spinat dazu den
habe ich bereits ausgedrückt bei
tiefgefrorenem spieler da hat man
natürlich immer ganz viel wasser mehr
dabei deswegen vorher gut ausdrücken mit
bratsche stehen hier mit an bis die
flüssigkeit fast verkocht ist und in der
zwischenzeit könnt ihr schon mal das
brot schneiden das habe ich jetzt schon
gemacht und gibt es brot hier in eine
große schüssel
irgendwie ist gerade keine schüssel groß
genug dafür auch meine spielers knödel
na ja ich gebe dann den rest gleich das
zur gänze bissle zusammen gefallen ist
da kommt die milch mit rein
die eier schlag ich dazu und den
parmesan reiben noch rein
[Musik]
kommt der spinat hier noch mit dazu ich
weiß ich habe eine größere schüssel
nehmen müssen aber ich habe keine zeit
es wird auch so funktionieren
jetzt wird sich die masse noch mit salz
pfeffer und muskatnuss und beim salz
müsste jetzt aufpassen weil ich ja schon
grana pagano mit dabei
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und jetzt noch ein bisschen muskat es
macht zwar spaß aber muskatnuss sollte
man nicht zu viel nehmen
ok und da ich jetzt mit dem kochlöffel
alles versauen würde nämlich jetzt
einfach die hände
so jetzt schön alles miteinander
vermengen und jetzt halt echt ganz schön
man kann wirklich das ganze brot
verwenden was man die ganze woche über
nicht gegessen habe und kannst alles
richtig leckeres weihnachtsessen dann
der familie geben oder
das ist doch toll und hier könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch laugenbrezel nehmen dann
nimmt das ganze nochmal einen viel
besseren geschmack an wird viel würziger
nehmt einfach alles was ihr gehabt hab
echt toller resteverwertung
und wenn jetzt merkt dass die
flüssigkeit nicht ausreicht könnt ihr
gerne noch ein bisschen milch dazugeben
ich habe halt dem spinat ganz lange
einkochen lassen das heißt wenn ihr den
spieler nicht ganz lange einkochen last
reicht die flüssigkeit wahrscheinlich
ansonsten gibt einfach noch ein bisschen
milch dazu und wenn es mal zu flüssig
geworden ist und ihr keine brötchen mehr
übrig habt könnt ihr auch zum beispiel
semmelknödel semmelbrösel einen
einrühren
jetzt habe ich es aber nicht so viel
flüssigkeit auf einmal
ich merke nämlich gerade das wird
eigentlich ganz gut ich habe gemerkt
dass bei mir der knödel teig noch nicht
ganz optimal ist und gebe deswegen jetzt
hier noch zwei esslöffel mehl dazu ich
werde die masse ordentlich durchgeknetet
und mehr gibt's auch schon bei mir
reicht die flüssigkeit auf jeden fall
auch aus und jetzt kann ich das ganze
hier so ein bisschen runter drücken
mit einem teller auch beschweren so
können alles wundervoll durchziehen und
ich kann später die knödel formen und
jetzt kann ich ihnen dazwischen seit
schon mal die nächste beilage und
natürlich auch den braten vorbereiten
jetzt geht es weiter mit dem
schwurgericht dafür verwende ich 250
gramm charlotten 60 milliliter öl etwa
1,2 kilogramm fleisch salz und pfeffer
eine prise zucker
hier habe ich drei esslöffel tomatenmark
etwas gemüsebrühe einen esslöffel mehl
und dann noch die gewürze rosmarin
kreuzkümmel etwas berg bohnenkraut und
ein lorbeerblatt
die schalotten habe ich jetzt schon
geschält dann nehme ich auch echt immer
nur die äußerste haut weg weil ansonsten
von charlotte nix übrig bleibt
und jetzt einfach ganz grob schneiden
es kann ich noch das fleisch schneiden
einfach in mundgerechte stücke
jetzt ist das fleisch geschnitten und
ich kann bereits den herd an machen und
den sport topf erhitzen ich mache jetzt
direkt alles im sport talk so kann ich
später das sportgericht einfach im
backofen stellen ihr könnt natürlich
auch eine pfanne nehmen und später
umfüllen
wenn ihr keinen sport talk habt das öl
ist jetzt heißt und jetzt brauche ich
zuerst einmal das fleisch darin an in
mehreren nationen stellen ich mach jetzt
drei schön heiß anbraten von allen
seiten und dann wieder rausnehmen
[Musik]
das gleiche setzt komplett fertig
angebraten jetzt sind die zwiebeln dran
also die charlotte die jetzt auch hier
schön anbraten für etwa vier bis fünf
minuten ein mittel hoher hitze
[Musik]
jetzt sind die zwiebeln angebraten und
ich kann das tomatenmark und das mehl
dazugeben und ganz kurz mit anbraten
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die masse mit etwas
gemüsebrühe ablöschen und hier könnt ihr
natürlich auch etwas gemüsebrühe durch
rotwein ersetzen oder auch komplett nur
gut wenn verwenden
[Musik]
jetzt kommt noch die gewürze dazu
erstmal eine prise zucker ottens kein
gewürz okay rosmarin dann habe ich hier
noch berg bohnenkraut das habe ich von
meinen eltern ein lorbeerblatt und das
wichtigste gewürz bei lam ist für mich
immer kreuzkümmel das hat mein papa
beigebracht weil das einfach den langen
geschmack so ein bisschen wegnimmt und
wirklich super dazu passt kurz einrühren
und dann kommt jetzt schon das fleisch
wieder dazu und ich meine lammfleisch
sowieso superzahl
jetzt war er noch kurz mit salz und
pfeffer abschmecken
[Musik]
jetzt könnte es entweder auf dem herd
bei ganz geringer hitze schmoren lassen
oder gibts in den backofen so mache ich
das jetzt hier kommt der deckel drauf
und dann kommt in den backofen bei 160
grad ober unterhitze für etwa zwei
stunden und es könnte wirklich auch
schon am vortag zubereiten und am
nächsten tag einfach nur noch aufwärmen
[Musik]
für die erste beilage verwende ich vier
rote spitz paprika eine unbehandelte
zitrone 250 gramm käse dann nämlich an
weißen weichkäse 150 frischkäse salz
pfeffer und etwas olivenöl
los gehts jetzt mit den beilagen ich hab
jetzt ihr die spitz paprika da schneide
ich jetzt den deckel weg und holen sie
dann aus den decken schön aufbewahren
den benutzten wir gleich wieder sieht
dann nämlich beim anrichten richtig gut
aus also hier innen einfach hier die
seitenwände vorsichtig wegschneiden mit
ihnen wie heißen die heißt dass die
kerne mit herausschneiden
und am deckel schneide ich jetzt hier
auch die kerne ganz vorsichtig weg
[Musik]
jetzt gehts schon direkt an die füllung
da nehme ich jetzt den käse und
zerbröseln und den weichkäse gibt es
einen verschiedenen fed stufen und ich
nehme immer gerne den mit 60 prozent
oder mit 65 weil ja im backofen eben
auch richtig toll schmilzt da ist dann
richtig schön cremig
mit dem ich jetzt in frischkäse dazu er
sorgt dafür dass ich gleich eine schöne
homogene masse habe
[Musik]
die sich da noch ein bisschen
zitronenschale abrede und pfeffer dazu
und dann ist die füllung im prinzip auch
schon fertig ihr könnt ihr natürlich
wenn ihr wollen auch anders
geschmacklich gestalten betonen schale
weglassen oder auch andere gewürze
zufügen
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich die paprika und für sie
einfach mit einem lasso fünf beutel ist
die masse einfach ein bisschen zu fest
aber so klappt es auch ganz gut einfach
immer ein bisschen nach hinten schieben
und dann wieder vorne was rein drücken
und dann kann ich jetzt die paprika noch
mit olivenöl bepinseln und die werden ja
später gegrillt ich mache jetzt auch
gleich so dass ich gleich noch die
möhren vorbereitet und die möhren kommen
dann vorher in den backofen das macht
man dann wirklich kurz vor dem verzehr
und die paprika die brauchen nicht so
lange wie die möhre die kommt dann
danach mit aufs gleiche blech aber jetzt
für die vorbereitung kann ich jetzt hier
alles auf dieses blech legen für die
chronik möhren verwende ich einen bund
junger möhren
ich habe ich jetzt zwei knoblauchzehen
etwas salz pfeffer essig
hier habe ich vier esslöffel olivenöl
und zwei esslöffel honig die möhren habe
ich jetzt bereits gewaschen und das grün
hinten entfernt ein bisschen grün lasse
ich gerne dran weil es einfach hübsch
aussieht jetzt werden sie halbiert und
da kann ich sie direkt in eine
auflaufform legen
ich könnte theoretisch auch ganz lassen
dann haben sie nur eine längere garzeit
[Musik]
die knoblauchzehe drücke ich jetzt ein
bisschen an kann sie schälen und dann
auch in scheiben schneiden und dazugeben
[Musik]
gut schreiben sind jetzt nicht mehr aber
es ist ganz groß geschnitten und hier
gebe ich jetzt noch das olivenöl dazu
den honig
honig und knoblauch perfekte kombi
bisschen salz ein bisschen es sich für
die säure zitronensaft könnt ihr auch
nehmen und thymian und jetzt am besten
einfach kurz mit den händen alles
vermischen und marinieren
das wäre für mich schon das perfekte
weihnachtsmenü einfach nur diese möhren
bisschen baguette dazu und fertig mehr
brauche ich nicht
[Musik]
meine vorbereitungen sind jetzt
abgeschlossen jetzt gehe ich noch mal an
die semmelknödel und forme sie und dann
können wir wirklich alles so zubereiten
dass wir gleich essen können zum knödel
formen nimmt ihr am besten und schälchen
mit wasser und jetzt könnt ihr hier in
den knödel teig ich mache jetzt auch
nicht so groß da finde ich es echt
hübsch wenn so schön klein sind und am
besten macht ihr so ihr formt ein knödel
und schmeißt dann schon mal in kochendes
wasser und schaut immer schön zusammen
hält und wenn der schönen zusammenhält
könnte dann die restlichen gebrochen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich alles vorbereitet und so
können die auch alles am vortag schon
vorbereiten die paprika kann nämlich
auch in den kühlschrank auch die möhren
können im kühlschrank gelagert werden
und die semmelknödel die könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch einfrieren und dann eben
am tag an dem es zubereiten wollte
einfach garen
ich habe jetzt noch das lamm im backofen
jetzt werde ich zuerst einmal die möhren
noch in den backofen geben
anschließend kommt da noch die paprika
dazu und die knödel werde ich dann in
der zwischenzeit in ein bisschen
gemüsebrühe garen
[Musik]
bei den knödel ist jetzt eigentlich nur
wichtig dass es wasser jetzt nicht
sprudelt kocht sondern dass es nur sieht
und ich legte jetzt hier ganz vorsichtig
rhein habe jetzt auch einen extra großen
topf und dann können sie hier einfach
ein bisschen durchgaren und je nach
größe brauchen sie so etwa 15 bis 20
minuten bei mir sind sie ja ziemlich
klein
deswegen dürften da 15 minuten reichen
[Musik]
kann steigen was anderes sagen nein ja
natürlich kommt man wohl mal die nerds
also wir probieren jetzt alle genau das
gulasch können da wie gesagt auch am
nächsten tag einfach wahr machen sonst
schön durch kannst du drei tage lang ist
nun ja gulasch geht immer kommt kommt
alle genau probiere ich denke es wird
durch ein hatte ihr müsst euch hinten
anstellen
im einzel war
alle hätten ein messer für mal da und so
das war eigentlich mein teller
also denkt ach kommt dann machen was
wäre ich ja komm ich richtig da ist ja
mal ein bisschen mehr weg sagt ach so
was jeder macht seinen teller sehr genau
und du musst jetzt probieren wo hat er
zwei beenden das video und die anderen
haben hier die probiert sie probieren
und ich muss hier erstmal andrea
caratsch helfen dass auch hier murata
fahrrad und so kann sich eben jeder das
nehmen worauf verlust hat ich probiere
jetzt mal für euch der mode hat brauchen
wir eine weile
ich hab das ding gemacht andreas war ich
habe die paprika kaputt gemacht
die spiele sind echt super witzig
probiert aber wo ich gehe mal ein
bisschen zur seite rücken ehrlich sein
das ist collage recht gut ich liebe dich
so wird sich der schlamm und ehrlich ich
glaube keiner draufkommen dass islam
gulasch wegen holz kümmern
kreuzkümmel dabei bleibt und auch
richtig gut trainiert der kindle auch
super spinat ja oft müssen sie hatte
apple gesagt das tust du normalerweise
kurz einatmen sommer auf die paprika
freue mich auch wo ich lieben schafskäse
und vor allem ist die paprika nicht
verkocht und die kommunen auch nicht
rechts also bald jetzt nach machen wollt
schaut auf meinem blog vorbei natürlich
könnt ihr das rezept auch verändern
abwandeln das sind ja nur ideen und
vorschläge für euch und wie gesagt hat
wir mal was es bei euch dieses jahr an
weihnachten zu essen gibt da würde ich
mich darüber freuen
oder gibt es gar nichts nur hier gibt es
auch gern auch kann aber probiert mal
sein kannst ruhig ehrlichkeit wenn es
nicht schmeckt dann
also gute nachricht bis zum nächsten mal
zu machen anstatt alle so wenig
aufgemacht kann mich jetzt auch die
hacke auf karim matmour der haut auch
eine reihe karin schneck
[Musik]